peu
[Musique]
bonsoir une nouvelle émission de jeu sur
la première chaîne
cette émission sera quotidien ou presque
lundi mardi mercredi jeudi vendredi et
dans cette émission
trois concurrents s'affrontent les voici
il faut d'abord venant de caen françoise
françoise boulot et cela vous êtes
étudiant trans'oise oui en espagnol en
2e année de préparer un duel c'est à
dire diplôme universitaire d'études
littéraires en spécialité espagnole
pourrait citer de son objectif à ta ta
ta ta ta ta et quand on a gagné le duel
que fait-on on prépare une licence si
tout va bien on va voir une naissance
bien sûr c'est ce que vous espérez à
côté de françois didierjean jean combes
qui levait le midi 2 40
monsieur bellemare où se trouve 40 à 20
km de béziers sur un tipi temps au mieux
des vignes et vous êtes vignerons vous
même nom représentant un lubrifiant et
outillage bien et puis à voter de gens
il ya henri henri les inscrits qui lui
est pilote de chasse
c'est exact soit vous n'êtes pas et
arras à reims à la 30e escadre vous
pilotez quel genre d'appareil mais vos
tourelles les voûtes et bien j'ai rami
ce jeu va procéder de la façon suivante
pour chaque épreuve
nos candidats seront confrontés avec
deux affirmations
l'une de ces affirmations est exact
l'autre bien entendu est fausse et a2a e
pardon de choisy et ils devront parier
sur leur choix
au départ ils possèdent tous 15 points
et ils pourront faire des paris entre 1
et 5 points mais cela nous y reviendrons
dans quelques instants
et grâce à ces affirmations nous
espérons au fur et à mesure de nos
émissions et bien extraire de nos
cervelles à un certain nombre d'idées
reçues qu'elles contiennent
voilà alors maintenant pour les autres
détails de ce jeu de l'aviron fur et à
mesure tout de suite nous regardons et
nous jouons ensemble avec la première
épreuve
[Applaudissements]
affirmation à picasso fut suspecté du
vol de la joconde affirmation b vous
voyez ici l'église du val de grâce à
paris
[Applaudissements]
je signale que pendant cette petite
musique que nos candidats marc leurs
réponses comme vous l'avez remarque ne
marquons secret bien entendu et vous
voyez que françoise et jean pense que
picasso a été suspectée niveau de la
joconde alors que henry lui penche
plutôt pour l'église du val de grâce il
semblerait que ce soit cela selon henry
et bien tout de suite maintenant nous
allons passer aux paris
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors françoise picasso suspecté du vol
de la joconde à votre avis combien de
points sur cette réponse vous paieriez
de problème pas très sûr du genre je
parie de près aussi il n'est pas très
sûr deviendra trop sûr de lui et en
réduit qui a cru voir le val de grâce
je lirai jusqu'à 3 3 points aux états
unis via militaire derrière
oui je vous souhaite pas d'y être bien
entendu la façade bien le mili bien eh
bien nous allons maintenant passer au
moment de la vérité bien sûr et je suis
navré henry mais ce n'était absolument
pas le val de grâce et l église de la
sorbonne qui ressemble un peu il faut
bien le dire tous les oreilles vous
perdez vos trois points alors que vous
aviez raison picasso fut suspecté du vol
de la joconde nous avons une pointe
d'ailleurs en ce qui concerne le val de
grâce et l'église de la sorbonne voulez
vous nous faire voir sept points voilà
alors vous voyez donc à gauche ce que
vous avez vu et à droite le val de grâce
en effet on peut confondre cet extrait
alors regardons les points maintenant en
vie vous vous retrouvez avec trois
points c'est à dire à 12
par contre avec deux points de plus 17
pour jean et avec également deux points
de plus 17 pour françois vous avez
compris le jeu bien entendu il s'agit
d'or au cours de l'émission de marquer
le plus de points possibles pour gagner
la partie chaque émission représente une
partie est en fin de semaine le grand
gagnant se voit sélectionnés pour la
semaine suivante aux deux challenger lui
seront opposés et li gagne 1000 francs
voilà et puis alors le champion des
champions celui qui en fin d'année aura
tenu le plus longtemps le plus de
semaine consécutive gagnera 100 mille
francs c'est à dire 10 millions
d'anciens francs mais nous ne sommes pas
là continuons à tester un peu notre
savoir avec la deuxième épreuve
affirmation à voici le grand acteur
comique max linder infirmation b voici
jean gabin et michel morgant dans
remorque
[Musique]
ils viennent également qu'une fois la
musique arrêté on ne peut plus changer
sa réponse est maintenant tous nos amis
ont répondu ah c'est à dire qu'il le
voit tous en affirmation à max l'inde
est par contre il ne pense pas que la
photo de droite est extraite de
remorques et bien le moment des paris
heydari fille françoise votre pari pour
max linder 5,5 points voit max moderne
et sûre d'elle jean cmpro chis un point
suis suis françoise il veut faire le
même score qu'elle est enfin autre 4 4 8
petits points heureusement pourquoi pas
exact envoyer un petit point devant les
panthers
entre nous on rire parce que c'est pas
du tout max mader s'est justifié lundi
oui vous avez bien répondu au début
henry vous aviez choisi besson s'était
bien remords que l'on a vu c'était bien
une photo de jean gabin et michel
morvant normand vous perdez tous des
points à leurs quatre points de moins
qu'un point de moins vous tombez à 8 ou
là ou un mal jean lui ou sa baisse
également pas mal il tomba combien j'en
tombe à 12 et enfin françoise elle tombe
de la même manière à 12 attention hein
et je rappelle qu'on ne peut pas parié
plus de points pour nonna n'est ce pas
et vous commencez à vous rapprocher 0
leur faites attention si les produits
affirmation à le principe du radar fut
énoncée en 1935 affirmation b la
première descente réel en parachute par
un homme eu lieu sous la révolution
[Applaudissements]
acculés ils répondent se changent
souvent
alors voilà le principe du radar fixe
non 5935 c'est l'opinion de françoise
quant à ces messieurs ils sont persuadés
que la première descente raide en
parachute eu lieu sous la révolution
l'instant des paris
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
françoise autres paris s'est trompé la
barre contre 1.5 wade très joueur et
henry ça me ferait descendre à 3 mais je
pense un quand même cinq points c'est
courageux vous écoute on a vite ça c'est
dangereux
eh bien henri 7 persuadé que la première
descente raide en parachute doré n'a eu
lieu sous la révolution et vous avez des
précisions à gaza la tête qu'il faisait
tout de suite le procès durera de la
chute annoncée dès 1911 par l'américain
james blake
n'est ce pas dans un dans un livre
d'ailleurs plus ou moins d'anticipation
henry vous regagnez cinq points c'est
très très bon pour vous quant à jean il
regagne cinq points aussi c'est ça
marche très bien pour deux
malheureusement françoise elle elle
descend et retrouve un point de moins 11
alors pour l'instant 17 agents 13 à
henry et 11 à françois ces gens qui est
en tête épreuves suivantes infirmation à
on trouve cet animal au pôle sud
affirmation b l'alligator est un animal
différent du caïman
les jeux sont faits françoise et jean
pense que l'alligator est différent du
caïman et henry lui est persuadé que cet
animal se trouve au pôle sud de bien eh
bien nous allons voir tout de suite les
paris alors pour le caïman et l'oeil à
tort différents françoise trois points
trois points
jean pour la même affirmation 4,4 points
et henry pour l'animal du pôle sud 3 3
points à 13 ans
eh bien oui vous allez vous allez vous
allez tomber à 10 il s'agit d'un
pingouin
c'était pas un manchot le manchot c'est
dans l'hémisphère sud mais le pingouin
lui lance donc vous perdez trois points
vous tombez à 10 et d'ailleurs je crois
qu'on a une preuve par contre de l'autre
affirmation médiateur est différent du
caïman oui voici les deux bébés est
évidemment à voir comme cela ces deux
sympathiques personnages ne sont pas
très différents il faut en fait les
retourner sur le ventre et les écailles
ventrale ne sont pas aussi fier comme
celle du caïman qui concerne la ligat
voyez vous aviez donc raison alors
maintenant vous marquez vos points vous
aviez joué quatre points vous êtes passé
donc à 21 points et vous avez j'ai trois
points vous êtes monté à 14
jean est toujours en tête il a pris le
large 21 14 et 10 pour henry qui est bon
dernier
voici les prochaines ventes
affirmation à son régiment polnareff
tenait la grosse caisse
affirmation b c'est jean dréjac qui
écrivit la musique célèbre du petit vin
blanc
[Applaudissements]
françoise je pense que polnareff ainsi
que jean d'ailleurs tiens la grosse
caisse et henri tient pour jean dréjac
qui a écrit la musique du petit wable
les parcs
alors françoise trois points je ne vous
ferais 17 vous gagnez genre pour sa part
m grosse casse oui la course aux cas
sociaux suffit pas pression et henri 5.5
poignets très sûr que jean dréjac avec
de la musique du petit pas mais je peux
me tromper
oui oui vous pouvez vous tromper vous
pouvez c'est d'ailleurs ce qui va
arriver j'en passe qui vous êtes trompés
oui c'est beau le cléac'h a écrit la
musique du petit vin blanc jean dréjac a
écrit les paroles la musique
cinq points c'est un moment ça va mal
jean vous aviez raison bien sûr que l'on
arrive sur la grosse caisse de régiments
et vous ajoutez donc un point vous avez
eu tort voyez vous la verrez ça rapporte
paris les 22 et
et françoise l espace à 17 le score 22
jan est en tête 17 françoise et secondes
et henry est très loin avec 5 points
on peut encore faire une épreuve c'est
possible alors et poursuivre affirmation
à baseball est une altération de base
ball du nom de son inventeur l'anglais
george basse affirmation b c'est grâce à
la reine marie-antoinette que le patin à
glace fut mis à l'honneur en france un
sac
pour les messieurs marie-antoinette
patiner sur la glace tandis que pour
mademoiselle monsieur georges barras a
bien inventé le baseball
nous allons voir les paris maintenant
[Musique]
c'est paris seront importants françoise
car je pense que nous en sommes à la
dernière épreuve alors françoise combien
parier cinq points sur georges basse
inventeur du baseball pour mario en 3d
le patin à glace 2.2 très prudent il un
bon score en changer dans la vence et
enfin henry si le dernier a pris 5,5
pour marie antoinette ou bien c'est le
zéro pointé les spas ou bien a lancé 10
séries ce sera plus honorable eh bien eh
bien eh bien vous avez raison henry
faisait bien jouer en effet c'est marie
antoinette en 1776 durant un hiver
rigoureux qui introduisit le patin à
glace et le mit à l'heure en france donc
10 points
pour henry oui deux points de mieux
pour jean puisqu'il avait également
décrété que c'était cela la bonne
affirmations malheureusement françoise
ou tombé à 12
et bien c'est quand même françoise qui
garde la deuxième place malgré la belle
remontée de henry a au tout dernier
moment le classement du jour est donc
extrêmement simple nous avons françoise
qui est seconde nous avons gens qui est
premier brillant premier avec 24 points
et enfin henry qui est dernier
aujourd'hui peut être demain le score
sera-t-il différent
alors voici le score final nous donnons
un point au tout dernier c'est henri
deux points à la 2e françoise et 3
points au premier
nous allons maintenant vous indiquez nos
éliminatoires je les prends de la main
de nos contrôleurs demain mardi 5
janvier épreuves éliminatoires à
châteaulin dans la salle de l'hôtel de
ville à 18 heures et mercredi 6 janvier
épreuves éliminatoires à quimper à la
maison des jeunes un impasse de l'odet à
18h aussi vous êtes tenté par rien que
la vérité
ami de châteaulin et de quimper
rendez-vous pour châteaulin mardi et
pour quimper mercredi à demain pour rien
qu'elle mérite
[Musique]